RACHEL: STRAIGHT TO A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
41-YEAR-OLD LOUISIANA
CONGRESSMAN-ELECT LUKE LETLOW
HAS DIED FROM COVID-19.
>> THE CONGRESSMAN WAS NEITHER
IT LOOKED LIKE IT WAS HIS HEART
RATHER THAN HIS LUNGS.
THIS IS VERY UNUSUAL AND DOES
NOT APPEAR FROM WHAT I’M HEARING
HE HAD UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
>> REACTION FROM CONGRESS IS
POURING IN, HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY TWEETING
OUR HEARTS BREAK TONIGHT AS WE
PROCESS THE NEWS OF CONGRESSMAN-
ELECT LUKE LETLOW’
PASSING AND I SPOKE WITH HIS
WIFE AND JUDY AND I ARE PRAYING
FOR HER AND HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI ALSO OFFERING HER
CONDOLENCES SAYING "AS THE HOUSE
GRIEVES CONGRESSMAN-ELECT LET
LOWE’S PASSING OUR SORROW IS
COMPOUNDED BY GRIEF OF SO MANY
FAMILIES SUFFERED LIVES CUT
SHORT BY THIS TERRIBLE VIRUS.
" LETLOW LEAVES BEHIND A WIFE
AND TWO YOUNG CHILDREN AND THE
FLAGS WILL FLY AT HALF STAFF
FOR THE CONGRESSMAN-ELECT’S
FUNERAL.
BACK TO YOU.
RACHEL: THANK YOU, TODD, IT IS
TERRIBLE NEWS, HOUSE MINORITY
WHIP STEVE SCALISE WAS WITH US
EARLIER TODAY AND HE WAS A
FRIEND OF THE CONGRESSMAN-ELECT
AND HERE IS WHAT HE HAS TO SAY
ABOUT THIS TERRIBLE PASSING.
>> IT WAS JUST HEARTBREAKING.
I MEAN, LUKE WAS A YOUNG GUY, 41
YEARS OLD, IN GREAT HEALTH AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO A BRIGHT
FUTURE.
HE HAD JUST GOTTEN ELECTED TO
CONGRESS THREE WEEKS AGO.
WE WOULD TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
THINGS HE WANTED TO DO, THE
COMMITTEES HE WANTED TO GET
ON AND TALK ABOUT A LOSS OF
SOMEONE WITH SO MUCH ENERGY,
HE’S GOT A BEAUTIFUL YOUNG
FAMILY.
I KNOW MY PRAYERS ARE WITH JULIA
, HIS TWO YOUNG KIDS, YOU
KNOW, EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS IS
JUST HEARTBREAKING.
OUR WHOLE DELEGATION IS
DEVASTATED AND LUKE IS ONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT EVERYBODY
LIKED.
>> YEAH, THAT’S WHAT MAKES IT
SO TOUGH, YOU KNOW, THIS IDEA
THAT HE’S 41 YEARS OLD LOOK AT
THAT FAMILY THERE, A WIFE AND
TWO YOUNG, YOUNG KIDS, FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF TO RALPH ABRAHAM,
HE RUNS FOR CONGRESS THE FIRST
TIME AND HE WINS.
GOES HE’S GOING TO GET SWORN IN